economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blanton quien ha
regresado pues de unas merecidas
vacaciones daniela bienvenida vamos a
comenzar hablando de ese grupo de países
de américa latina que van a ampliar sus
zonas marítimas protegidas bienvenidas
hola santiago gracias por la bienvenida
feliz de estar acá de nuevo pues le
cuento que los presidentes de costa rica
colombia ecuador y panamá firmaron este
martes en la cope 26 una declaración
para la conservación y manejo de los
ecosistemas en el corredor marino del
pacífico este eso aplica para regiones
como la isla del coco en costa rica
malpelo en colombia y cohiba en panamá
pero también para islas galápagos
santiago en ecuador que tiene una zona
protegida de 138 mil kilómetros
cuadrados y que el gobierno pretende
extender en unas 60.000 hectáreas más en
las que se limitan o prohíben
actividades como la pesca una de
nuestras enviadas especiales a la
conferencia climática de la onu luisa
pulido habló del tema con el presidente
de ese país guillermo lasso quien
explicó cómo se va a financiar el
proyecto escuchemos
es un mecanismo de canje de deuda por
conservación de la deuda ecuatoriana
correcto canje de deuda ecuatoriana todo
parte por el apoyo de una institución
financiera multilateral o unilateral que
permita la emisión de bonos que puedan
ser esos dineros que se permita adquirir
deuda ecuatoriana con descuentos por lo
tanto en la utilidad nominal de deuda
iría a un fideicomiso para beneficio del
ministerio de ambiente del ecuador que
lo va a utilizar única y exclusivamente
para la conservación de galápagos y esta
área de reserva marina danielle hablemos
ahora de eeuu que anunció la primera
represalia económica contra el gobierno
de etiopía por la situación en la región
de tigres pues al menos eso es lo que
parece según lo que dice el presidente
joe biden quien decidió que a partir del
próximo primero de enero cortara el
acceso de etiopía al comercio libre de
aranceles a eeuu por lo que considera
violaciones de derechos humanos en este
país esa es la primera respuesta
contundente al conflicto en la región de
tigre y que ha provocado desplazamientos
masivos y también una hambruna la
suspensión de los beneficios amenaza
principalmente a la industria textil en
2020 santiago de los 237 millones de
dólares en exportaciones etíopes libres
de impuestos hacia la unión americana el
90 por ciento fue de textiles y de
prendas de vestir hay que agregar que
ese país no es un gran exportador sin
embargo algunas fábricas producen para
gigantes como calvin klein piro o tommy
hilfiger o la misma sueca echan en la
decisión que incluye otros países como
malí y guinea fue anunciada justo cuando
los rebeldes de tigre y mente
incrementan su ofensiva y ahora avanzan
sobre la vecina región de amara por eso
el gobierno declaró el estado de
emergencia como ya lo contábamos daniela
pues hay que ver cuál es el impacto que
esto tiene en etiopía que es una de las
economías más grandes del continente
africano hablemos ahora de afganistán en
donde ya no va a poder ser posible el
uso de divisas santiago la agencia
reuters
a un portavoz de los talibanes para
decir que sólo se permitirá el uso de la
moneda local llamada afgano en lugar de
divisas aunque no dice desde cuando una
medida que seguramente va a provocar más
trastornos en una economía que está al
borde del colapso por la abrupta
retirada del apoyo internacional la
medida se produjo horas después de un
ataque con al menos dos docenas de
víctimas mortales en el hospital militar
más grande del país en kabul a el uso de
dólares santiago estadounidenses está
muy extendido en los mercados de
afganistán mientras que las áreas
fronterizas utilizan la moneda de países
vecinos como pakistán para el comercio
ya que este país afronta pues una
escasez también de efectivo también los
indicadores como lo fue las bolsas hoy
pues un triple récord en wall street de
en medio de una temporada de ganancias
empresariales sólidas y a la espera de
los resultados de la reunión de la fed
en europa también favorecen los buenos
resultados la bolsa de parís también
tocó máximo histórico y en américa
latina la bolsa de lima perdió al medio
de las protestas mineras que motivaron
un desplome del sol peruano la cifra del
día para el cierre de estas vacaciones y
de la sexy pues son 65 mil 500 millones
de dólares esa es la previsión de ventas
de la vacuna anti kobe de 19
desarrollada por la farmacéutica
estadounidense pfizer y su socio by un
tec entre 2021 y 2022 36 mil millones de
este año 29 mil millones el próximo la
empresa dice que tiene capacidad de
producir 4 mil millones de dosis en 2020
muchas gracias daniela es todo por el
momento en la economía siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]